on a dit que vous étiez prêts à suivre
macron c'est vrai ou pas non c'est faux
c'est faux s'il faut en plus je le
suivrai pas presse que ça fragilise pas
une candidature qu'on commence à fleurir
les plan b pour sauver les plans b les
plans c est les plans h du nom de
quelqu'un d'autre on les prend ton temps
manga très ministre deux ans tu l'on
passait là encore on passe pas de la
casquette de j'ai jamais fait de
politique je viens de rothschild hélas
au coup par coup peut-être que toute
cette gauche pourraient s'unir deviner
derrière derrière qui derrière
christiane taubira il m'en parle de plus
en plus je ne crois pas que christiane
taubira qui a déjà été candidate à la
présidentielle puisse demain puisque
c'est la question que je me pose
être élue présidente de la république à
la baisse sur un mois est historique
66300 chômeurs de mois en catégorie à
c'est à dire sans aucune activité un
chiffre immédiatement salué par françois
hollande qui parle d'une tendance
installée depuis le début de l'année
notre politique économique porte ses
fruits
le chômage baisse avec 90 mille
demandeurs d'emploi de moins depuis
janvier il faut poursuivre ce soir on a
des résultats qui confiant le fait qu'il
ya une inversion de la courbe du chômage
qui est engagée qui est constaté 2030
soit en dix huit migrants en toi ont
quitté hier le bidonville ont été
transférés vers des centaines de centres
d'accueil répartis un peu partout sur le
territoire
nous avons renoncé à voir une véritable
politique de reconduite à la frontière
des migrants illégaux il faut reprendre
cette politique il faudra lui donner
aussi une dimension européenne alors
qu'il négocie son entrée au gouvernement
avec nicolas sarkozy
voici ce qu'il aurait prononcées je ne
veux pas de l'intérieur je n'aime pas
les flics pas la justice je déteste les
juges la plus folle que vous ayez fait
raison des propos d'il ya plusieurs
années que j'ai pu tenir sur certains
points d'autres sont déformés ou ou
tronquées et en tout cas je n'ai pas pu
dire ça parce que je n'en pense pas un
mot
est stagiaire à la préfecture de la
martinique et pour les besoins d'une
visite du premier ministre de l'époque
qui s'appelait jacques chirac j'ai été
obligée d'emprunter une voiture qui
n'était absolument pas la mienne à
quelqu'un que je ne connaissais pas marc
4% le chiffre c'est le dernier sondage
pour vous pour la primaire en même temps
certains françois hollande avait démarré
à 3% à la prière de la journée il est il
a accédé à l'élite y croyez encore
j'espère faire mieux je fais pitié par
quatre pour cent des français sont
satisfaits de l'action de françois
hollande selon le dernier baromètre du
cevipof
c'est décidément le chiffre du jour les
plus mignonnes arrêté qu'à la télévision
une alliance avec en sus un bureau au
fond c'est un passeport pour la non
réforme c'est le passeport pour
l'immobilisme qui sait que c'est la
politique on monte on est content on
change les cochons mais j'ai toujours la
même porcherie
oui